hallo leute hier sieben mal waren und
wir kommen zu einem neuen investigativen
journalistisch gut recherchierten video
und heute stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage ist teuer gleich
besser wenn ich an kleidung denke dann
ist designermode in meinem verständnis
natürlich irgendwie hochwertiger besser
von der qualität von der produktion und
einen drum und dran aber ich glaube das
vermittelt mehrheit der preis weil man
ziemlich viel für designer klamotten
bezahlt und ist ist ja nicht immer so
also ich glaube adidas hat nicht so gute
produktions umstände und ist ja doch
relativ teuer wenn man eine lieberose
dazu vergleicht und ich bin gerade noch
dabei germany's ich hasse dieses wort
und da ich gerade dabei wenn gntm
produkte zu testen habe ich von der
marke bouillon london glaube ich dass
diese ausgesprochen wird ein kleid
bestellt was 940 euro kostet es ist ein
sehr schönes gelbes kleid da sage ich
gar nicht zu und da ist wahrscheinlich
ein toller designer hinter aber mir
stellt sich die frage ist es wirklich
auch von der qualität so dass man sagen
kann ja das sind 940 euro ganz klar oder
bezahlt man am ende nur draufhalten
bekannter designer gemacht hat ich weiß
kurz vor pandemie ende gehört das
natürlich zu den allerwichtigsten fragen
die wir uns stellen sollten natürlich
hier ist das gute stück also dafür dass
das 940 euro gekostet hat kann man doch
sagen das ostseebad eine bessere
verpackungs methode hat ich hoffe
wirklich dass ich dieses kleid noch
zurückschicken kann und als video beweis
will ich hier schon mal zeigen das ist
so angekommen mit einem loch
ich habe mir so in xativa seine liegen
da drin 940 euro kostet auf dem designer
bin ich wie gesagt über germany's next
topmodel aufmerksam geworden weil alex
den job bekommen hat für den designer
und sie haben halt so ein fotoshooting
damit gemacht dass die operation
beginnen das ist das teuerste
kleidungsstück was sie jemals bestellt
habe gekauft was auch immer
katar sei
es gab ein geschenk dazu für 1000 euro
eine sonnencreme unten brief ich muss
sagen wenn ich mir etwas für 1000 euro
in wirklichkeit bestellen würde denn
dann sieht es sehr bereich sieht aber
gar nicht luxuriös aus so was steht denn
hier in meinem brief da sahen wir nur
eine grußkarte
ich kann ich bin gut das unterscheidet
auf jeden fall schon mal von normalen
online bestellungen dass man das halt
nicht in so einem sicherheits
kleiderbügel dingens kirchens bekommt
schon lang erster sneak peek 1000 euro
kleid hängt jetzt neben mir und ich pack
mal die anderen aus das wurde auch in
london designt welches kleid haben wir
hier
ich habe hier einst von closen klosett
klose etwas haben wir hier
und noch eins von chlorid das sind
unsere beiden kleider aus der
günstigsten kategorie günstig sind sie
immer noch nicht 70 und 60 euro gemerkt
natürlich ich hab leider geholt die sich
schon relativ ähnlich sind gelb und
relativ lang
damit man auch um vergleich hat das ist
unser günstigsten das ist mango für 50
euro
also wir haben 15 50 60 70 das sind so
die günstigeren kategorie hier ist unser
zweites quasi designerkleid für 250 euro
von michael hofmann oma doch hier gibt's
schon mehr luxus ich meine 250 euro das
ist immer noch eine preiskategorie da
würde ich mir kein kleid holen
auch gelb macht den stoff hier das sieht
ein bisschen aus wie eine couch und dann
würde ich sagen probieren wir mal die
kleider alle an und ja ich habe jetzt
hier einmal das günstigste kleid für 60
euro von klose
es sieht bisher naja so also ich mein
ich hab's noch nicht angezogen es könnte
ja noch eine überraschung sein feld
schirmer auf das ist so schnüre bin
natürlich kein absoluter profi was die
verarbeitung an der stoff fühlt sich gut
an
das ist schon mal die hauptsache es ist
ein kleid für 60 euro es wird jetzt
nicht katastrophal verarbeitet sein aber
es ist schon
es hat hier schon so seine macken würde
ich mal sagen ansonsten sieht es hier
vorne ganz gut aus der reißverschluss
funktioniert das innenleben ich sehe
gerade das hat schon ein kleid mit
taschen das ist gut
made in uk macht mit der information was
ihr möchte das ist 100% polyester auch
wenn ihr die marke klo sind kennt
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
jetzt gibts ne transition 123 ja und
obwohl es hat schon was sofortiges muss
aber unbedingt mal kurz dieses großen
situation ändern und man kann ich fühle
mich wie eine fee wenn einfach eine
sänfte befehl
[Musik]
ja also ich meine es auch immer noch
eine geschmackssache das geht ja jetzt
hier nicht darum ob mir der schnitt so
an sich aber eigentlich schon ich bin so
ein bisschen hin- und hergerissen ich
finde es schön und ich muss auch sagen
für 70 euro das ist soll und stabiler
preis wären würde ich halt auch zahlen
natürlich auch mehr wenn es mir gefällt
also es ist schon mal gut so vom preis
leistungsverhältnis man kriegt ein
schönes kleid ein bisschen bisschen noch
mäßig aber das ist halt geschmackssache
kommen wir jetzt zum mittleren kategorie
damit jetzt gespannt hier ist unser
kleid woraus besteht das kleid
es fühlt sich auf jeden fall nicht an
wie polyester eine sehr süße messe die
am anfang 19 prozent baumwolle 3 10
prozent butter modell habe ich noch nie
gehört und 68 prozent viskose das mutter
könnte jetzt mehr dazu sagen ich bin da
keine schneiderinnen oder ganz was in
der art deswegen keine ahnung daraus
hätte ich auch gerne eine couch und ich
weiß nicht ob das ein gutes zeichen ist
dass sich daraus auch gerne eine couch
hätte verarbeitung am einmal den test am
ärmel hier hat man auf jeden fall die
nähte wurden so darf wie hat man das
denn geschafft die nähte wurden hier
versteckt die verarbeitung sieht auf
jeden fall um einiges besser aus
ich würde sagen wir probieren es einfach
mal an kulinarischen ich mache mal ganz
kurz zum anderen kleid sagen seht ihr
hier den reißverschluss das endstück ist
nicht dran genäht und hier löst sich
auch schon der reißverschluss also
selbst für 70 euro kriegt man nicht
perfektion was sagen wir zu diesem kleid
beim anziehen dass mir auf jeden fall
schon mal aufgefallen das ist sehr viel
stoff ist was ich aber gar nicht schlimm
finde weil dadurch hat man bei der
bewegung solche wasser artigen
ich glaube es ist der fall eingetreten
vor dem ich angst hatte ich mag das
kleid
ich glaube dass es so ein allround kleid
was du so winter auch an haben könnte
ist aber auch im sommer wenn du eine
couch bist dann kannst du auch einiges
falsch machen
andererseits wirkt ein bisschen um sich
ich bin ehrlich ich hatte das gefühl das
kleid passt zu mir
okay aber sprechen jetzt mal noch mal
über die qualität es fühlt sich sehr gut
an es hat so einen hochwertigen stoff
also man merkt richtig man hat hier was
gutes an keine naht ist irgendwie
komisch die verarbeitung sind wirklich
sehr sehr gut aus ich glaube es ist auch
relativ pflegeleicht weil es so ein
festerer stoff ist
ich mag das klein bin so unsicher ich
ziehe mir schwer doch ist es also diese
preiskategorie hat mich überzeugt wenn
man zeit für 250 euro aber es wirkt wie
ein kleid was du wirklich ein leben lang
an haben kannst nichts passiert wird
ich glaube das problem mit diesem kleid
ist einfach dass ich mich damit fühle
wie mit 40 neue fans an 40-jährige da
draußen aber sieht so ein bisschen zu
alt für mich aus hey hey das wichtigste
ist es hat mich nicht enttäuscht und da
danach müssen wir wohl das lasso raus
wir holen jetzt das teuerste klarheit
queen of transition
jetzt sehen sie auch vom ersten blick
erinnert es mich wirklich an einem
hautengen kleid und ich weiß nicht warum
aber es ist so dieser stoff ihr könnt
mir noch nicht sagen das kannst so bei
h&m geben sogar das schild sieht aus
wenn ich das in dem secondhand sehen
würde würde ich bei diesem schild nicht
denken
dies ist kleider 1000 euro gekostet
jetzt wissen wir es ist 100% seide
es ist ein bisschen schief was mir angst
macht bei solche sachen bedeutet immer
dass man diesen teil schon sehen kann
ich kenne mit umgezogen sind über 1000
euro leute ich kenne mich jetzt nun
wirklich nicht aus
also alles was ich dazu sage ist
ungelernt aber hier in dieser stelle
sich außerhalb schon so ein bisschen
überreizt wäre und die fäden so ein
bisschen rausgucken 4000 euro geht das
aber die ganz strengen mit dem zeitung
pauli wenn das bei h&m hängen würde ich
würde den unterschied nicht erkennen ich
weiß h&m cloud bei den designern
deswegen sieht alles nach emmaus aber
ich sage ich bin ja nur von meiner sicht
das ding ist dass es halt so ein feiner
stoffes dass man natürlich wie hier so
die nähte sieht und wo es dann quasi auf
hört denkt man auch wo sollte man sonst
verstecken aber gerade dadurch dass man
das so sieht wo die nähte hier sind
wieso 1000 euro gefühl gerade jetzt
kommt der große moment ich probiere es
an 123 erste frage geklärt
bei dieter und ich habe das gefühl
dieses kleid macht eine fantastische
figur
also es gibt also ein richtiges so
gefühle von so nah wie seide hat es gibt
so auf der haut
ja hätte so schiffs mit meinen
fingernägeln irgendwas hier rein zu
kratzen weil dann wisst was ich meine
das sei schon den hintern leute kapseln
klebe bh darunter an damit man halt
nicht sieht aber selbst diesen klebe bh
sieht also dieses kleid ist sehr schön
aber ich verstehe es halt nicht ist es
so ein kleid was man so auch so ein
bikini anders geht und dann zur am
strand entlang läuft für 1000 euro oder
das ist ein kleid für leute die keine
bhs tragen und keine unterwäsche eine
anmerkung noch das sei zwar seide sein
aber ich habe jetzt nicht das gefühl von
u
seiten glatt und ich muss sagen des
stoffes halt ernst nicht kratzig und er
wirkt sehr empfindlich ich ziehe mir
noch mal 1 50 euro kleidern und dann
reden wir über das fazit ich kann hier
nicht mehr an diesen dingen stehen noch
ein letzter blick
1000 euro wenn mir jemand sagen würde
dass das designer-kleid wäre würde ich
genauso glauben so viel ahnung kann mich
davon qualität sollte seinen preis haben
wie bei dem 52 euro pride ich finde aber
nur wenn etwas 1000 euro kostet sind die
erwartungen so hoch dass sie dann doch
ganz schön aber vielleicht noch einfach
nicht meine welt ich finde aber auch 50
euro für so ein kleid ist fragwürdig
deswegen secondhand kaufen ist immer die
beste alternative die trends kommen
sowieso alle wieder von allen kleidern
wichtig an hatte die welt mit uns
tatsächlich am besten
es ist nicht so durchsichtig ist aber
leicht an diese club klosett marke hat
mich echt enttäuscht von der qualität
das war der reißverschluss kaputt war
ein bisschen doof ich habe noch ein
kleid von klosett geholt das sieht
besser aus wie sieht ihr jede
reißverschluss aus gut verarbeitet ich
glaube ich habe einfach ein fehlgriff
mit dem ersten platz
das sieht die man aber noch mal
ähnlicher und die moral von der
geschicht macht doch was ihr wollt es
mir doch egal
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
bis dahin tschüssi copski eure
gelbe vanessa